when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
it's a warning the batman starring
robert pattinson is the third take on
the caped crusader in the past decade
but the march reboot of the dc hero has
already started developing two spin-off
projects one centering on the penguin
and the other surrounding the gotham
police department after watching the
film i and many fans can't help but
think that one of batman's most beloved
villains could take center stage in
future films with the riddler catwoman
and the penguin all being used in this
first movie future batman sequels are
sure to dive deeper into the vast array
of comic villains some of which like mr
freeze and court of owls have already
been teased by pattinson and director
matt reeves and as much as it would be
fun to see mr freeze on the big screen
again no disrespect to arnie when it
comes to the bat there will always be
speculation surrounding one villain in
particular
that's the joker why so serious
in every iteration of batman so far
we've had a joker christian had heath
michael had jack mark hamill has a
devoted fan base around his animated
version and of course joaquin brought us
the oscar-worthy origin story and jared
has been running around the dc
multiverse with appearances in suicide
squad and the snyder cut of justice
league even the cw is getting on board
casting nick kregan in batwoman as the
first person of color to play the role
batman
had the joker
batwoman
you've got me
but the question remains will robert
pattinson get his joker i mean you could
say that it's inevitable but rumors have
swirled for months now that there will
be a joker in this particular film with
some outlets reporting that there are
plans for the role to be featured in the
trilogy's second and third films at the
time casting for the role had not yet
begun but in the years since there's
been one actor who joined the batman who
has role in the film that he repeatedly
refuses to elaborate on and that's barry
kyogen that's right druid himself plays
an alarmingly small role in the batman
for an actor of his caliber and adding
fuel to this fire kyogen's brother has
jokingly responded to fans connections
posting on facebook that his brother is
playing the joker in the new batman
comes fighting words my friend
after the official credit sheet surfaced
online entertainment news outlet the
direct noted kyogen who was originally
announced as playing gotham city police
officer stanley merkel is now listed as
unseen arkham prisoner and further to
that the credits list a crew member mike
moreno as the prosthetics designer for
both the penguin and unseen arkham
prisoner now colin farrell spoke at
length about his transformation using
both facial and bodily prosthetics which
made him almost unrecognizable in the
film having the same crew member doing
prosthetics for kyogen suggests a
similar transformation having seen the
film i can attest that even though it is
not explicitly stated
that the joker is there
spoiler territory here guys big spoilers
it is heavily assumed
i can say that it is heavily assumed so
that being said this whole officer
stanley merkel casting could be a red
herring or
it could be matt reeve's take on the
joker's origin story which is famously
mysterious and open to interpretation
but what do you think are you excited to
see the batman and if the rumors are
true would barry kyogen make a good joke
or let us know in the comments below see
you next time
you